preguntarle qué pasó con este proyecto
no de méxico y argentina maneja usted de
información al respecto
solamente la que se tiene a la mano
porque porque estoy involucrada
básicamente a dos empresas privadas las
cuales además tienen evidentemente todos
los contratos de confidencialidad
etcétera por cierto en el caso de méxico
específicamente los contratos han sido
reservados para todas las instancias
durante cinco años entonces poco lo que
se sabe de manera oficial ahora que sí
sabemos que la manufactura de estas
vacunas pues realizada en argentina y
fue enviada a la planta de laboratorios
y lo montó aquí en méxico para ser
acondicionada es decir envasada ya hace
algunos meses lo que parece que sucede
es que el lyon moto no tuvo la capacidad
de compra o de adquisición para los
suficientes el suficiente número de
envases hay que entender que es de
repente bueno estas empresas que son
especialistas en hacer algo de repente
se enfrentan a grandes volúmenes del
suministro y esto es lo que ha impedido
que hasta el momento vayan pudiendo
envasar aparentemente y lo que nos han
dicho de manera oficial es que
a finales del mes de abril que ya llegó
a principios del mes de mayo se estarían
liberando los primeros millones de estas
vacunas envasados es decir si esta
semana que comienza no sucede algo
realmente tendremos que cuestionarnos
qué es lo que lo que pasó porque esto ya
tiene un retraso importante de más de
siete semanas está bastante una semana
clave entonces para ver qué sucederá
ahora otra pregunta que ambos países sí
hicieron acuerdos con sputnik verdad
méxico por un lado para envasarla en
argentina
si hay una planta que la produce que
quizás comenzaría la producción masiva
en junio lo que se prevé hay una
posibilidad cree usted de que lleguen
esos millones de dosis pero ya no de
astrazéneca sino de sputnik
no es probable sin embargo hay que
entender que son dos contratos aparte el
contrato de astrazéneca para
latinoamérica es un contrato que se
realizó de la mano de la fundación
carlos slim y que ya tenía un
financiamiento previo esto o sea eso es
algo incidental los que realizaron
sputnik con sputnik el gobierno de
argentina y el gobierno de mexico son
independientes y son acuerdos
gubernamentales es decir uno no debería
quitar el otro ahora en caso de
cobertura por supuesto que cualquier
número de vacunas de la que sea ayudan
en este momento a toda latinoamérica